what the star player look like in each
generation hey we got Floyd the plumber
that's on the wing right now making a
move and getting to the basket and
finishing his skill set is just so
magical he's a witch no he's human but
oh my Jesus he is shooting a little far
oh my God he is here's Floyd the plumber
again after 10 years in prison finally
back in the oh my God and he's doing
more with a dream no we're ready
here we got sweet money Lou Billy Ray
put in the moves on that jive turkey go
ahead do something with it oh he's gonna
do it his signature fall back baby use
that glass that bad mama jama's in
transition around the back
think you know I just love the 80s the
socks are high the shorts are higher and
the players are high and having
unprotected sex but nothing bad could
come from that star player Joe Walter
putting the moves on that man being a
magician and throwing it down ever since
MJ retired a few years back newcomer
Jordan Michael has been on an absolute
tear good here's Jordan Michael in
transition and we're gonna stop and put
some moves on him and get right back and
going for this switch
[Music]
low rice cake dancing on them literally
dancing on them look at those combos put
him in NBA Street right now
[Music]